you're so
wonderful yes I love you too I love you
and I love you happy Wednesday everyone
so remember those stories you'd hear
about a firefighter who sets a fire so
he can ride in and save the day but
instead the house burns down that
reminds me of Joe and the Border he
torches the border and now we're
supposed to trust the same guy who
started this raging Blaze to put it out
you know it's like believing OJ when he
said he was going to find his wife's
killer
he's still looking he is he is so do we
give him more matches and gas or look
for someone with a fire extinguisher and
a pulse that's the question Joe Biden
asked America yesterday during a speech
that reminded me of Winston Churchill
primarily because Winston Churchill is
also
dead all indications are this bill won't
even move forward to the sener floor why
a simple reason Donald Trump because
Donald Trump thinks it's bad for him
politically he'd rather weaponize this
issue than actually Solve IT Trump and
the Maggie Republicans said no because
they're afraid of Donald
Trump afraid of Donald Trump the
Republicans have to decide who do they
serve Donald Trump or the American
people every day between now and
November the American people are going
to know that the only reason the border
is not secure is Donald Trump and his
Maggie Republican friends folks we've
got to move passes toxic
politics that is amazing first of all he
asks who do the Republicans serve this
is the man wearing the Ukrainian flag
because they gave money to his kid who
do you serve but the short-term Buzz of
this woke postering inevitably gave way
to the reality hangover that was visible
yesterday on the president's face look
at him it's painful to watch it's got to
the point that now Joe just barks Maga
whenever he can't make a real argument
lucky for him it's only two syllables
even luckier Trump is only
one but it's his answer for everything
he's like a sex addict who only knows
one
position and we're the ones getting
screwed but it seems something has
finally dawned on Joe that spiteful
anti-trump tantrum he threw when he took
office reversing roughly 90 Trump irab
border policies has now become the
defining feature of his administration
and he's become a melting angry ice
sculpture and then there's Homeland
Security director Alejandro
maoris sorry it's hard to give a thumbs
up to a man who looks like a
thumb he's failed miserably to defend
our borders so when the House of
Representatives voted Tuesday evening to
impeach him it should have been what
figure skaters call a slam
dunk but three Republicans these fellows
right here on your screen joined the
Dems in voting against what would have
been the second ever impeachment of a
sitting cabinet official so write down
those names so you can vote against them
or at least sign them up on
grinder our audience doesn't know
grinder and good for you Mike Gallagher
posted on X why he voted against
impeachment quote creating a new lower
standard for impeachment will set a
dangerous new precedent that will be
weaponized against future Republicans
Administration
it will only further pry openen the
Pandora's box of Perpetual
impeachment so you get this people those
GOP defectors didn't vote to impeach
Trump didn't vote to impeach because it
would lead to the Dems doing it as well
do we live in the Twilight Zone sir
Gallagher the Dems already impeached
Trump not once but twice did we already
forget that is Biden's dementia
contagious does Maga now stand for
making Alzheimer's great
again what an argument we don't want to
hit them cuz they'll hit us back well
then why are you in the damn ring you're
fighting for us remember anyway
Republicans say they'll try their hand
at impeaching mayorcas again maybe in a
few years when our Southern border
starts at
Nebraska yeah but like I told my
assistant when she wanted a day off for
her mother's funeral don't hold your
breath but it's not really about
mayorcas it's about Joe we wouldn't have
this crisis had B not rescinded Trump's
border policies and just left remain in
Mexico in place he prefers his policy of
remain in basement
instead the problem with yesterday was
that ignored one unignorable fact This
Disaster was not occurring under Trump
and that the Republican house now are as
weak as Jerry nadler's
spinter if there's one thing
establishment Republicans love to do
it's lose gracefully but as they lose so
do we cash strapped local governments
are now spending billions for the care
and feeding of new arrivals with no work
permits and limited job skills and less
respect for the law than ilhan Omar on
her wedding night
damn I don't even know what that means
the video of two NYPD cops assaulted by
Venezuelan thugs exposes the issue that
Dems had labeled racist just for
bringing it up migrant crime
so Venezuela empties its prisons and we
get a crime wave what did you expect
they broke the laws in their own country
and now they're free to roam in a bigger
richer country it's like offering a free
bucket of fried Twinkies and then
shocked that Joy bayar shows
up on the foreign policy front Biden
decided to link securing the border to
funding for Foreign Wars now let me get
this straight Russia's at war with
Ukraine Hamas terrorists slaughtered
Israeli citizens oh yeah Jo it's
Hamas there is some movement and I don't
want to I don't want
to well maybe choose my words damn
there's some movement there's been a
response
from the
uh there's been a
response from the
opposition but um it yes I'm sorry from
Hamas oh my God quick somebody gets
smelling salts and then put them in a
little girl's
[Applause]
hair that's not good that is so not good
at least he didn't say extreme magga
Republicans it's Hamas you dumbass maybe
ease up on the embalming fluid it's not
even funny anymore really I feel bad
saying that cuz I this is terrible but
those Wars mean America apparently
doesn't get a southern border if anybody
can explain to me how this works I
promise to give you Brian km's home
phone
number he goes to bed at
8:30 so these countries they have sacred
borders but America's looks like Walmart
on a Black Friday of course the experts
will say look man you got to fight the
bad guys over there so they don't come
here fine I get that but why not make it
harder for them to get in here before
they flee from the wars that we are
fighting there I know I
know it it makes too much sense like
muting your TV whenever Jesse's
on the truth is the Border crisis is
like luminol for the crime scene that is
the Biden Administration it's detecting
blood all over and Joe's Alibi is
holding up about as well as the Border
itself thanks to his incurable TDS Joe
has managed to make our border as
incontinent as he is can he stop the
flow at all I bet we'll get the same old
answer
depends welcome tonight's
guest he took a night off from banging
your ex to be here tonight comedian Jeff
D she's so bright Joe Biden keeps
walking towards her campaign
Communications expert Aaron p
and here we go she took OIC and gained
weight New York Times bestselling author
and fox contributor
[Applause]
cattoo and when he plays Monopoly he
uses real houses New York Times
best-selling author comedian and former
NWA world
[Applause]
champion Jeff you know because you're an
expert on immigration I was going to ask
you what your solution is but then I
watched those clips again of Joe Biden
and I realized these are not gaffs
anymore this is just the status quo of
his behavior it's kind of scary I even
feel bad making jokes about it now yeah
it's hard to make it funny yeah like it
really is like you just watch it go this
is embarrassing that's the leader I know
have like JFK like we choose to go to
the Moon you know that's get jacked up
you get hard watching that you watch
this you just go ah this is what we're
doing yeah it's it's very embarrassing
it's very
also what is the plan just don't talk
about it I I at least we have a position
here but then you ask people like well
you know you you when you go to a
country you should probably follow the
rules to like get into that country I
can't just go to Australia and they go
hey don't say that yeah what about these
guys beat up a cup they're not even
citizen they go whoa whoa racist but
what's the plan like can we talk about
it like there has to be some other side
yeah the only side they are concerned
with are for the people coming in it's
the most bizarre thing a border actually
has two sides
and and like if you bring up your
concerns you're a bigot right just by
talking about it like that's pretty
scary also and not very funny that we
can't even talk about it without being
like this is you're you're problematic
what happened to your caller by the way
it's uh this is a special
cut told it looks I was told it looks
good you're like Jeff Dy hip doctor look
I I'm here to tell you got cancer but
what are you doing
later eron that is the doctor I'd
be that is the doctor you'd be you've
only got 3 months to live but two months
to
love I love that all right Aon I
apologize for that um what do you do you
think not impeaching mayorcas is a big
deal I mean it really I mean it's like I
guess life goes on is this a big defeat
no it's not because one they'll be able
to bring it up again and you know it I
think the least surprising part of this
is that like it's taking a while to get
things done in Congress that's the same
song in dance I worked on the hill for
years I haven't been there for a few
years but really not much has changed
the way we make the change here is we
elect somebody else to the White House
the reason we are facing three and a
half to four times more border crossings
in a two-year period under Joe Biden
than we did under Donald Trump is
because of Joe Biden let alone the 90
executive actions that he took away from
the Trump Administration purely because
he said oop Donald Trump that's a no for
me building the border wall he stopped
doing that part of the border wall was
also like Dam infrastructure in Texas
and he was like good luck everybody like
everything he did has been bad and has
only made the Border worse people want
to see this end you can't believe like
you can't be shocked that it's going to
take Congress a while to get this right
you need a leader in the White House
who's willing to take action to get it
right because it's clear between Biden
and my orcus no one is going to close
the southern border of the United States
yeah he would rather forgive student
loans yeah and will do and has done that
and then and catch and release people in
the United States you enter the country
illegally hey you got a one-way ticket
you beat an NYPD cop you might make it
to California but that's that's that is
the tenant of their policy right now the
core of their policy
is yeah you know cat I was just I I
think I was caught off guard watching
Biden again yes it I think we all know
now why he's not doing the Super Bowl
interview
yes I mean it's bad dead serious what
okay if that's your audition tape what
gig could you get right no like like
just three it's only 3 minutes it
there's no only in that 3 minutes okay
like the Super Bowl is supposed to be
fun I hear and like that was that's like
he looks miserable they would you but
how why is I mean the thing is why isn't
that clip everywhere like I I'm I'm
pleading ignorance that is the first
time I saw too first time I I mean this
the first time because they all look the
same you're like oh you know what's
crazy is that I don't care what you know
party your from what you believe
whenever you're watching Joe Biden speak
everyone watches him like
this like like like what's going to
happen you know like that's not like how
you should watch them like oh like like
like and you're just like heartbroken
and scared the whole time this isn't
normal none of this is normal it's
disturbing he's so sad yeah like this he
shouldn't be he shouldn't be have to do
that no at at this point they need to
pull they need one of those big things
to take them away
we owe George W bush a big apology we
gave that we raped that guy over the
coals for saying like fool me once and
then you know losing his train of
thought this guy every day it's so
normal to us now we just go that's how
we talk normal I thought he was just
split in the diff like he's got a 10
minute speech but if he combines it all
together he can get it done in three
minutes I I thought it was just a you
know I'll say three or four things at
the exact same
time which is a higher level of thinking
that's true which you know we just don't
get it my bad Mr President I'll work on
my this
is just the incident with the the border
patrol officers and their horses M his
ass should have been out of there yeah
and this is on Republicans this this is
why we need term limits they care more
about getting
reelected than doing the right
thing his his laxidasical
effort with the border with the way he
treats the men and women who protect the
Border how about the mothers who came to
Congress he didn't show up because he
was quote in a meeting with Mexico you
should have brought their asses too but
it goes back to the same
thing Republicans are full of and this
proves it they say they want change who
care if I know that being a leader and
doing the right thing and getting a
person this man out here who's failed
and there's no one can argue that he
hasn't means I might not get reelected
but I did my job that was better for my
people fine next man up so be it I did
my part but this says more this you know
we always want to go at the left and say
when they're doing this this says more
about us and the spineless people that
supposedly are conservatives that know
that this man has cost money is ruined
lives there was people that couldn't
leave their homes because everyone
thought they were whipping black people
and think about that that's what and
you're serving for pay and that's how
you're being treated that's just one
didn't show up for the moms then they
was ly fine making like border agents
were letting people drowned in the water
yes it didn't matter what horrible thing
that he said but you just didn't want
them to come back at you yeah turn in
your little pin and your tie and go home
yeah all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else